as if you needed it because you've got
these massive stars in the show in the
cast what was your reaction when you got
the call and they said yeah someone's
joining us this season it's Meryl Streep
yeah it was nuts it was it's it seems
it's like it's like the end of a joke
like oh yeah let's get Meryl Streep for
that anyway let's and then it's real I
heard like a don't tell anyone but we
might be getting Meryl Streep and we
really did think like never ever would
that happen but and but then the next
thing I found myself saying is I am on a
show with Meryl Streep so it's yes it's
crazy yeah my staff for years has been
saying you know we got Meryl Streep and
that they did know do you ever get
self-conscious you mean you're working
with all these iconic actresses and you
are a very famous fellow very talented
but they're making a little
self-conscious that you're working with
this calibre of calves I do you know
it's it's hard because everyone in the
cast is so incredibly famous and and and
talented and it's it's crazy that I I
did one time with with Reese Witherspoon
and I we were shooting a scene it was
the last scene we had together for the
season two and we were it was a scene in
a therapist office and she in between
takes she said something funny and I
just went like that but a string of snot
like came out and then wrapped around my
nose and I just like excused myself and
went and found the makeup person got a
Kleenex and wiped it off but from then
on until like from the six months from
then and I came back and thought should
I reference what just happened to really
acknowledge it yeah acknowledge it
should I make a joke about it or just
apologize for the disgusting thing that
just happened and
and and I didn't and then so afterwards
for the six months afterwards until the
show premiered I was like should I text
her and like make a joke about the snot
like should I acknowledge and I never
did but I tortured myself about it for
all that time and then at the premiere
in New York I was like should I go up to
her and say something about this not
just as like a light-hearted thing just
to acknowledge and so I never did know
you Whitewood on let me tell you as a
friend yeah they know too much time has
gone by now you can't yeah the only
thing you can do now is maybe on your
deathbed yes summon Rhys to your side
and go thus not miss not I'm sorry and
then died and died does have that be the
last words you ever spoke that's great
and I was already planning for my last
words to be the snot